[Music]
in mozambique 80 percent of people
depend on agriculture and food
production
fish meat and vegetables are part of the
culture but fisheries decline in recent
years have led to fish scarcity and
increase of prices
also poor production techniques and high
costs of farming have made fish a
delicacy that few can afford many people
rely on starchy foods and vegetables
leading to unbalanced diets that lack
protein
recent cyclones devastated the country
destroying lives and livelihoods and
creating new challenges for food
security and nutrition the covid19
pandemic added to the challenge of
maintaining fragile food systems
thousands of farmers have been affected
grassa michelle patroness of the
historic site of shillin benner former
first lady of mozambique and of south
africa is a strong advocate for
nutrition women and youth empowerment
she asked fao to work with her
foundation to rebuild the agricultural
food systems in the province of gaza
placing aquaculture at the core of local
transformation fao is promoting
integrated aquaculture as a way to
generate fish production and create jobs
for young people and women that's
critical for protecting households from
more climate shocks and building
resilience to global shocks such as
covid19
in chilembena fao is providing
assistance and capacity building on new
technologies and business skills in an
integrated project where aquaculture
agriculture and livestock complement
each other it's about giving men and
women new opportunities to generate
their own production using innovative
integrated aquaculture solutions
the project aims to
restart local food production with an
integrated system that includes fish
livestock and crops
develop fish farming recycle waste and
save energy while maintaining ecological
balance build capacity for women and
youth from local agricultural schools
despite the challenges imposed by the
covid19 pandemic the project has already
proven to be a success almost a year
since it began participants have
produced 16 tons of fish 2.5 hectares of
maize and sweet potatoes and bread
chickens and rabbits
many people particularly local women and
young students from two polytechnic
schools have benefited from fao's
training as well as research and
development they have learned good
agricultural practices using good seeds
and feeds fertilization and irrigation
techniques and the need for markets and
marketing this project gives them
reasons to believe they can start their
own business on fish farming chickens
maize beans or other value chain
improving nutrition and increasing
resilience to climate change threats and
crises is essential for the people of
mozambique
it can only be achieved by building
better and sustainable food systems
[Music]
you